every day Jerusalem's Old City receives
hundreds of visitors on their pilgrimage
to the Church of the Holy Sepulchre to
see what is believed to be the grave of
Jesus for many Christians it's a sacred
space but instead of stillness and
reflection hear the sounds of
construction specialists from Greece
have come to reinforce the chapel which
is in danger of collapse the British
were the last to make an effort to
stabilize it and that was in the 1940s
we had corrosion of the internal iron
bars which were connecting the stones
you might see here the last one we have
investigated and this is the reason that
later on they English put this iron cage
you see but it doesn't bear the stress
anymore we are at the end of its
lifetime it's taken decades for all the
Christian communities involved to reach
a consensus about this restoration work
every repair every alteration must be
approved by consensus that provision has
been in place for centuries
the Gunther Kia is the whole church has
been unsafe since the earthquake of 1927
it's been renovated bit by bit the dome
was restored in 2000 but people haven't
dared to undertake work on the grave
itself because it's such a delicate
issue not just structurally speaking but
because of the very question of how the
grave should be restored pilgrims are
still allowed to view the Crypt in small
groups the interior is due for
renovation as well according to
Christian belief this is the place where
Jesus was buried and resurrected they're
removing layer after layer repairing it
and then putting it back together some
of the work is done in the early morning
hours or late at night when the church
is closed it's a sensitive area for a
construction site but visitors are full
of understanding in such a way but when
I came here and then I sold the
scaffolding around it and all that
that's what but the feeling as a
Christian is still the same and it is a
very important place for Christianity
who needs a lot of maintenance and maybe
a bit of renovation as long as they they
I mean they maintain they maintained the
integrity of the whole thing the the
original beauty of the design and
everything they could do so many things
I mean light that place up they could do
a little bit of fuss renovation that
doesn't really need so much of time but
nothing in this hallowed Church proceeds
very quickly the reinforcements work is
expected to last at least a year however
long the construction work takes
it's a rare demonstration of unity among
all the Christian communities in
Jerusalem